Sandra let's bring in Byron York Chief
political correspondent for the
Washington examiner and a Fox News
contributor so Byron as we mentioned a
moment ago impeachment proceedings
against the DHS secretary begin next
week meantime with Brett Bear last night
uh mayor is is saying well we hang on a
minute this isn't just an American
problem other countries are affected too
listen here Brett the numbers are
historic the numbers are extraordinarily
large this is something that is not
specific to the the United States's
Southern border uh this is something
that we are seeing throughout the
hemisphere and throughout the world we
have U increase in authoritarian regimes
we have more extreme weather events that
are driving people from their homes all
right now first uh what he said there
about the weather bill maluan has talked
to a lot of migrants and not a one of
them he told us yesterday has mentioned
climate change is a reason why they're
trying to get into the United States and
secondly while immigration is a problem
for other countries particularly in
Europe those countries are doing
something about it and we're not
Byron yeah President Biden also
attributes a lot of this flow to Poverty
but it is just a fact that uh millions
of people uh in the poorer parts of the
world would indeed like to come to the
United States for more money and a
better life but that's been true for
decades and decades and decades uh and
it does not account for the fact
that Joe Biden actually opened the door
in 2021 and we've seen the number of
illegal crossers coming into the United
States just Skyrocket in the years since
then and and he still refuses to turn
this a crisis watch this exchange with
Brett last night yeah but you do think
it's a crisis
now Brett it is a challenge uh that uh
we have been addressing vigorously with
all of the tools and resources that we
have been provided we are asking for
more tools and resources all right so
addressing those two points first of all
everybody says it's a crisis except for
people in the administration secondly
all the tools and resources that they're
asking for Byron and yet another huge
expenditure that they're begging
Congress for would do nothing to stem
the flow of migration it would deal with
it once they got here to the United
States but would do nothing to stop the
pull factor of people coming across the
border and that's a point that uh
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson uh
made in a in a report that they've
released just this morning talking about
how much more has been spent on the
border since Joe Biden became president
but at the same time it's only increased
the flow I'll give you just a few
numbers in fiscal year 2021 Congress
appropriated
$486 billion for the bord the next year
that went up to
$6.23 billion the next year 23 it went
up to
$7.15 billion and in those same years
the number of monthly encounters that is
illegal crossers who are actually
encountered Crossing into the United
States Grew From 163,000 a month in 2021
to 230,000 a month to 266,000 a month
and now it's at 308,000 a month so
members uh of the House Republicans in
the house are saying we keep giving more
and more and more money and the flow
increases which is and it's because the
administration is using the money to
accommodate and to facilitate uh the
flow of illegal crossers into the United
States and then their relocation from
the border to other parts of the country
it's not being used to actually stop the
flow so President Biden is giving his
first campaign speech in the 3 o'l hour
this afternoon it's not likely that he's
going to mention illegal immigration is
one of the things that he's going to
address but one of the things he will do
is point out uh January the 6th and
Donald Trump calling him a threat to
democracy it's backed up by this new
Biden ad watch this real quick there's
something dangerous happened in America
there's an extremist movement does not
share the basic beliefs in our democracy
I mean it's no wonder that Biden wants
to talk about President Trump in January
the 6th because let's put up this
Monmouth poll from the beginning of
December he is underwater on so many
major issues including look look at this
he's underwater on climate change he's
got to change the subject Byron no no
question about that yeah you know it's
really interesting Biden is kicking off
2024 with a couple of speeches devoted
to some of the darkest moments in US
history this speech uh about January 6th
and then his next speech in a few days
he's going to go to Emanuel am Church in
Charleston where um a white gunman
murdered uh nine black parishioners back
in 2015 when Biden was vice president as
a matter of fact um and so the the the
common thread of all of these speeches
is going to be that Donald Trump and
Maga pose an existential danger to the
United States that democracy in the
United States might come to an end and I
think what you're what you said is
exactly right Biden really has little
Choice uh but to make this the theme of
his campaign because first majorities of
Americans both Republic an and Democrats
view him as too old for a second term
and second they disapprove of almost
everything he's done in office so he's
going to try to make the election about
Trump y he's not going to make it about
are you better off now than you were
four years ago I would assume no way
good to see you thanks so much
appreciate it have a good weekend thank
you John hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaylee mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Easter
or sets your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights